THE RUSSIAN LEADER WILL DO NEXT.
>> Aishah: THANK YOU, TREY.
>> John: LET'S BRING IN MORGAN,
SHE'S HERE IN THE STUDIO WITH
US, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
HOW IS NASHVILLE?
>> IT'S THE BEST.
>> HOW IS THE TWANG?
>> I HAVE TO HAVE A BOURBON OR
TWO.
>> John: WE CAN ARRANGE THAT.
2500 PEOPLE ARE ARRESTED, DON'T
WANT TO GO IN UKRAINE, NOT
CONVINCED IT'S THE RIGHT THING
DO, IS THIS RAISING ANY
SIGNIFICANT PRESSURE ON PUTIN?
>> I THINK SO.
INITIALLY HIS PROPAGANDA MACHINE
WAS WORKING QUITE WELL.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT EARLIER THIS
YEAR, WHEN I SORT OF SAW A
FAILURE IN OUR INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
COUNTER HIS PROPAGANDA AT HOME.
SO DEFINITELY FOR THE FIRST 4 OR
5 MONTHS OF THIS WAR THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE WERE ON HIS SIDE, THEY
BELIEVED IT.
NOW YOU ARE SEEING A TURN AS
PEOPLE COME HOME IN BODY BAGS.
SEEING THE PROTEST AS YOU
MENTIONED AND OVER 37 CITIES,
CALLING UP HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE, AND IF YOU ARE A
PARENT, YOU KNOW IN RUSSIA YOU
KNOW YOU ARE PROBABLY SENDING
THEIR CHILD TO DEATH.
YOU COULD LOOK ONLINE AND
TWITTER THEY ARE SHOWING VIDEOS
OF RUSTED MACHINE GUNS AND
TERRIBLE EQUIPMENT THEY ARE
ASSIGNED.
SO IT'S HARD TO WIN THE
PROPAGANDA WAR WHEN PEOPLE ARE
COMING HOME IN BODY BAGS.
HOW DOES THAT AFFECT HIS
CALCULATION?
PUTIN'S BACK IS AGAINST THE
WALL.
AND AS THE CIA DIRECTOR NOTED,
AGING CAN BE AS GREAT PERILOUS
AS ONES ARISING.
WE CANNOT TAKE ANYTHING HE SAYS
LIGHTLY, WE HAVE TO TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
THE SAME I AM TOO, THE UNITED
STATES AND THE WEST CANNOT ALLOW
OURSELVES TO BE BLACKMAILED FROM
A NUCLEAR WEAPONS PERSPECTIVE BY
RUSSIA, BY PUTIN.
WE CANNOT LET HIM BLACKMAIL US
INTO TELLING THE UKRAINIANS THAT
THEY HAVE TO STOP OR THAT WE
HAVE TO EASE UP PRESSURE.
BECAUSE IF WE ALLOW PUTIN TO DO
THAT, IF WE BLINK IN THE NUCLEAR
THREATS, EVERYBODY WILL SEE IT
AS A TACTIC AGAINST THE WEST.
>> Aishah: THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
MADE CLEAR WHAT THE CONSEQUENCES
WOULD BE, SAY RUSSIA USES
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
I BELIEVE JAKE SULLIVAN SAID THE
U.S. WOULD ACT DECISIVELY.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S ENOUGH?
>> WE HAVE TO DEFINE IT MORE IN
THE PUBLIC DOMAIN.
I ASSUME AND HOPE THERE ARE
CLEAR RED LINES COMMUNICATED
BEHIND THE SCENES TO THE
RUSSIANS.
I DON'T KNOW, I'M NOT CURRENTLY
COMMUNICATING TO THEM, BUT I
KNOW SITTING IN MANY MEETINGS IN
MIKE POMPEO, YOU CAN LEAVE NO
WIGGLE ROOM, YOU HAVE TO
ESTABLISH THE CLEAR RED LINES
AND THE ADMINISTRATION MAY NOT
KNOW WHAT IT IS YET BUT HEARING
A LOT OF TALK AND CHATTER OF
PEOPLE SAYING WE NEED TO GIVE
PUTIN THE OFF RAMP, MAYBE GIVE
THE UKRAINIANS TO CONCEDE.
THAT IS THE WRONG APPROACH
BECAUSE XI JINPING WILL USE THAT
AND USE THE TACTIC WITH IRAN.
AND THE AYATOLLAH IN IRAN WILL
USE IT AS IT RELATES TO GETTING
A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
WE CANNOT BE BLACKMAILED BY
ROGUE STATES.
>> NOT THE BORDER BETWEEN RUSSIA
AND UKRAINE, BUT MEXICO AND THE
UNITED STATES.
SINCE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE, 267,000
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS HAVE COME
ACROSS THAT BORDER AND WE KNOW
HOW PERILOUS IT IS BECAUSE I
MEAN, WE HAVE 800 PEOPLE I THINK
AT LAST COUNT THIS YEAR WHO HAVE
DIED TRYING TO MAKE THAT
PERILOUS JOURNEY ACROSS THE
BORDER.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT KIDS BEING
SENT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, ABOUT FIVE
TIMES AS MANY UNACCOMPANIED
MIGRANT CHILDREN OF THE LAST
YEAR OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER AND A LOT OF TIMES
PARENTS SEND THEIR CHILDREN
ACROSS THE BORDER WITH THE DRUG
CARTELS.
MAYBE THEY THINK THEY ARE
SENDING THE CHILDREN TO A BETTER
LIFE BUT THEY ARE NOT.
AS MANY TIMES, THEY ARE SENDING
THEM TO THE DEATH.
AND YOUNG TEENAGE WOMEN, YOU ARE
SEEING RAPES, SEEING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
I THINK WE NEED TO START
THINKING ABOUT THE DRUG CARTELS
MORE LIKE TERRORIST
ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY ARE SET TO MAKE $13 BILLION
IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
SMUGGLING THE FENTANYL DRUGS AND
WHATEVER ELSE THEY ARE SMUGGLING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
SIMILAR TO ISIS OR AL-QAEDA, THE
WAY THEY TREAT WOMEN AND
CHILDREN, THE RAPINGS, THE
MURDERS, EVEN SOME REPORTS OF
BEHEADINGS, THESE ARE THE ACT OF
TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS AND THEY
ARE ACTING THIS WAY BECAUSE
THERE IS AN OPEN BORDER POLICY
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO GET AWAY
WITH IT.
I WAS THERE A FEW WEEKS AGO, I
SAW THE OPEN BORDER MYSELF, I
SAW THE SMUGGLERS HAVE PEOPLE
CLIMB OVER THE FENCE AND RAN
INTO AMERICA.
I SAW IT MYSELF.
>> Aishah: I WONDER WHAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE FOR PEOPLE TO TALK
ABOUT IT AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
WE SHOW THE NUMBERS AND THE
VISUALS ALL THE TIME BUT IT'S
NOT GETTING ANYWHERE IN
WASHINGTON.
>> WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
A HUMANE BORDER POLICY AND THEY
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE AND RAPE
AND HUMAN TRAFFIC YOUNG PEOPLE
AND HURT CHILDREN, THAT IS NOT A
HUMANE POLICY, ANYTHING BUT.
>> John: AND AS WE SAW ON THE
SCREEN, TH